[Musique]
bienvenue donc là on est au départ du
trou numéro un de la baroche que
parcours qui va accueillir accueillir la
ryder cup à la fin du mois et on à
commencer bien évidemment par le trou
numéro un trou numéro un qui va être un
endroit qu'un c'est particulier parce
que premier coup parce que
je sais pas si vous avez l'occasion de
voir mais vous avez là derrière des
tribunes qui sont les plus grandes
construite sur sur aucune des riders que
précédente
il va d'ailleurs un peu plus de 6000
spectateurs donc la pression du public
et la pression de ce trou qui est
également un trou qui est assez
difficile à jouer
selon même les mots de sergio garcia qui
a des trous les plus difficiles sûr sûr
sûr les sur les tournois du circuit
européen avec de l'eau assez
accueillante sur la partie gauche du
fairway et sur la partie droite du
fairway en rêve qui peut être très
pénalisant si toutefois la mise en jeu
était lâché un petit peu trop à droite
[Musique]
ici on est sur la retombée on va dire
idéal de ce trou du marois donc là
admettons qu'on ait fait une mise en jeu
idéal ici le coup suivant reste quand
même assez délicat à jouer parce que
pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'était un
green qui construit volant tout temps
tout en largeur d'accord avec assez peu
de profondeur
donc il va falloir choisir le bon club
parce que si le coût est trop court bien
évidemment le voir sera pénalisé par
l'obstacle d'eau pieds devant si le coût
est trop long il ya deux magnifiques
banker qui qui attendent les balles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là on est sur le green du trou
demeurant un green sur lequel on a
engagé des travaux en amont la ryder cup
ça peut être très délicat s'il a loupé
le green seal est dans le bunker où dans
l'horreur parce que la balle pour
l'arrêter sera difficile à arrêter avec
bien évidemment la punition de l'eau qui
sera qui sera derrière c'est ensuite
parce qu'en fait il ya des pentes qu'on
voit pas forcément beaucoup sur ce green
l'a donc un pain à green à ces traîtres
sinon mise à part ceux mis à part cela
les positions de bras paul et plus elle
est plus facile seront les positions à
l'entrée parce que là les pentes sont
qu'un relativement relativement molle
mais il n'empêche que très honnêtement
la difficulté dans l' attaque de glynn
ce sera d'éviter les bunkers d'éviter
surf où il sera impossible à arrêter une
balle qui si malheureusement les mâles
touché finira dans l'eau
[Musique]